[Music]
now there's a hero of mine and I'm using
hero in the feminine sense oh sorry I'll
come to her in a moment and one of the
laws of nature which i think is probably
the most important of all the laws of
nature so let's get it out of the way is
the conservation of energy and you are
all familiar with what happens when a
ball rises and comes back down again it
might have a lot of kinetic energy
initially it loses kinetic energy as it
requires potential energy then as it
drops back down again it loses potential
energy and kinetic energy but the sum of
the two potential and kinetic energies
remains constant so this energy is
conserved and the conservation of energy
is hugely important largely because it
is the foundation of causality I mean in
order for us to be able to talk about
the sequence of events that take place
in take and talk about it rationally you
need causality and in order to have
causality you need some kind of
policeman in the in the universe and the
policeman but I think underlies obeying
allowing for causality is the is the
conservation of energy that we've got a
certain amount of energy in the universe
and anything you do cannot change by one
calorie or one herb or these days one
Joule
the total amount of energy in the
universe doesn't mean to say that
nothing happens just means to say that
there is a global constraint on the
total amount of energy hugely important
causality is the basis if you like of
science
and science in collaboration with
causality is the basis of understanding
so hugely hugely important and nice my
hero is Emmie nota German mathematician
driven out of girding and by misogyny
ending up in Pennsylvania and um it
seems to me that all mathematicians
either die close to zero or close to
infinity and regrettably she was one of
the unlucky ones who died close to zero
but in the course of her rather brief
life she established a number of
extraordinary results in mathematics and
the one theorem that I want to mention
to you it's not going to be an elaborate
theorem is that I actually established
that wherever you have a conservation
law that is wherever you have a law
which says that nothing changes even
though events take place whenever you
have a conservation law you have an
underlying symmetry so conservation laws
emerge from symmetry the conservation of
energy is a conservation law so any
notice theorem implies that there is an
underlying symmetry so if we can
identify the symmetry and if we can
understand where the symmetry comes from
then we show have established the origin
of that conservation or the conservation
of energy in this case and the immunity
theorem says that the conservation of
energy is due to the symmetry of time
specifically it is due to the uniformity
of time so that if time goes tick tick
tick tick tick tick uniformly on the
cosmic scale then energy is conserved so
we can account for the conservation of
energy by asking why time on a cosmic
scale is uniform and the so let me just
say that if time were not uniform so
tick tick tick tick tick and so on then
energy would not be conserved I mean
probably this non uniform with non
uniformity of time it's like it happens
in some lectures such as this that there
are dragging moments and and quick
moments and so on but really you've got
to identify but the conservation of
energy is due to the uniformity of time
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the Institute of Arts
and ideas at IAI TV
you